the Communist Party Congress is in full
swing in Beijing and Chinese stocks are
up that was Premier League
vows to support economic growth he made
the remarks at the ongoing Congress and
just a day after China delayed the
release of economic indicators scheduled
for publication this week including the
country's third quarter GDP data
investors are closely watching the
Congress where the party's General
Secretary jijinping is expected to be
handed a third term in office
now despite government leaders stressing
that things are looking up Chinese
economic growth has recently faltered
for a long-term boost State and party
leader Xi Jinping is relying on domestic
consumption however there is a problem
China's population is aging last year
roughly 18 percent of the population
were younger than 14 and 13 percent were
older than 65. now the United Nations
are expecting a significant shift by the
Year 2050. by then according to a new
study only 11 percent of the Chinese
will be under 14 and seniors over 65
will make up a full third of the
nation's population
now for some more insight let's bring in
Valerie tan she's an analyst at the
Mercator Institute for China studies uh
welcome to DW Valerie after Decades of a
one-child policy um the Communist party
is advising or allowing families to have
three children now why is China's birth
rate still one of the lows in the world
though
yeah that we should really highlight in
light of the party Congress going on in
Beijing right now it's the lack of women
representation in Chinese politics when
you don't have enough Women Within who
are represented in government than
women's issues such as relating to birth
rates such as relating to gender
equality are not represented in policy
documents and that is why one of the
reasons key reasons underlying this is
that on the ground then women in China
feel economically and socially insecure
and they don't see the need to have more
than one or have any children at all so
you know despite State and partying
leader Xi Jinping saying his country
will establish a policy system to to
boost birth rates I mean there have been
uh measures like tax deductions longer
maternal maternity leave enhanced
medical insurance all these things have
put in place they're not showing a real
impact are they
well you can't just simply throw money
at a problem and expect people to rush
to the hospitals I have kids at home the
issue really is more than just about
money and financial support sure those
are important things as well but there
are real structural issues on the ground
that have not been resolved if you
realize that in the past year we have
been hearing a spade of high profile
cases where there's violence harassment
and domestic abuse cases really coming
up to the surface in China those issues
and those cases really reflect the lack
of enforcement to protect women when
women don't feel secure in society when
they don't feel economically secure then
they don't see the point like I said
earlier about having children because
their children won't feel safe in an
environment in that environment that is
what impact is this uh demographic trend
having on economic growth
crisis China as highlighted by the
United Nations as highlighted by the
population planning authorities within
China as well and one big key thing that
we would like to highlight here as well
is that the population planning
department in China is releasing a
survey with results about how women and
how families feel about having shared so
that's one thing to watch but in the
longer term this means productivity and
production and Manufacturing will take a
hit because in the global competition
for talents when you have an aging
population
people are asked to work longer at older
age they're forced to retire that is not
something that the Chinese Society will
be able to accept and also like will the
younger generation will we see more
people be able to take on more jobs and
this is a big transition and adjustment
for China right now Valerie at the same
time one could argue that countries like
Japan like Germany they're also facing
an aging population but there hasn't
been a real letdown in growth when it
comes uh to this matter
is something that China has also been
watching and drawing lessons from that
is why you see the government investing
a lot in robotics automation autonomous
cars trying to like really automate
processes that used to be done by humans
but at the same time then you also look
at Social policies is there enough of a
social welfare net to support the Asian
population because if you don't have
enough resources to do that that is
greater Financial pressure on families
who are like you know mostly one child
right greater Financial pressure for
them to support their Elder parents
their grandparents and their in-laws
then that means a lower capacity for
them to consume and spend right Valerie
tan of the Mercator Institute for China
studies Valerie thank you